Let's get into audience questions for the
weekend.
Very good.
Yeah.
This week, the first one comes from a reddit
user.
I never say this right.
Nostalgic.
Say in Cyan [inaudible].
I know it's some video game game thing and
I never know how to say it.
Anyway, the question is how come the left
doesn't have grifters like the right, I love
this question because there's actually a lot
to it.
It might sound like an ad Hominem.
It's a way to criticize right-wingers.
Listen, this is a real thing.
The right has these grifters who able to,
they suffer from audience capture where they
start modifying what it is that they put out
there in order to appeal to an audience, even
if these are not really their political beliefs,
but that would only work within or in front
of a certain audience because of the cults
of personality, the right rewards.
This is one of the big differences between
independent left-wing media and independent
right-wing media.
I've seen it myself.
I can have people who like 95% of what I say
and as soon as they don't like some 5%, I
say, Oh, you know what?
I don't think Tulsi Gabber is a great president.
Or Hey, you know what?
I think the squad lacks a lot of the political,
uh, skills to, um, make progress on some of
these issues that are important to them.
Or, Hey, you know what?
I don't think Israel is a uniquely blood lusting
bad actor.
While I do disagree with their administration
and their foreign policy, there is no cult
of personality around me because immediately
people who have been with me for years will
completely abandoned me.
Now we can talk about whether that's good
or bad for the movement, but with the right
you see cults of personality develop such
that these individuals can do no wrong.
They build a following for their personality,
not what they stand for, not what they believe
and not what they say, but for the sort of
role that they are given by the right.
The left both doesn't allow these grifters
to build around cults of personality and is
quite frankly not interested in them in the
same way we've talked before about how you
will see very different reactions from left
and right when there is a political scandal
ones.
I'm not talking about Hillary's emails, right?
I'm talking about actual scandals, the right,
we'll try to cover them up and make excuses
for the people and try to make the scandal
go away to keep the person in power or even
give them more power.
As we saw with Brett Kavanaugh on the left,
when we find out Anthony Wiener has been caught
sexting with a 15 year old or whatever, people
just want them out.
We want to move on.
We have ideas and principles and policies
that we want to see made a reality.
And as soon as we see that somebody is behaving
in a way that doesn't make sense, we want
them out.
There was this audio recording that was recently
covered up by Republicans in Texas where a
Republican came up with a Republican Hitlist
of Republicans to primary and Republican said
this, the recording of this conversation is
so damaging.
We've got to cover it up.
If I found out that someone on the left took
place in such a meeting and I found it, that
the, and I found it distasteful or disadvantageous,
I would want the audio tape out.
I would want to figure out who did the wrong
thing and I would want them out.
So again, um, the, the, the left simply doesn't
allow the grifting to become profitable the
way the right does.
It doesn't create an environment in which
one would succeed by doing that.
Now I know I'm not stupid.
I know half the youtube comments will be,
but David, you are a grifter.
That's not an actual argument.
I hope you understand.
Um, it is the audiences that decide whether
grifting will work on the left or on the right.
It is the audiences that decide can someone
build a career around a cult of personality
merely because some think tank is pumping
money into them and what you see is that the
answers are yes on the right and mostly no
on the left.